[Music]
welcome to the climate show with me tom
heap in seven days when the records for
temperature may have been safe but
drought records are buckling it has been
the driest july for more than a century
on top of a pretty parched year and two
parts of the british isles have
announced a hosepipe ban
over in the u.s they're still plagued by
deadly weather extremes but there's also
been a promising political breakthrough
in washington and we'll bring you news
on both
we'll be looking back on the life of the
scientists and inventor james lovelock
whose gaia theory helped shape how we
think about our world
and we're going to start by digging
below the dust ashes and political weeds
to something close to dr lovelock's
heart the soil itself the growing medium
for so much of life on earth is in
trouble a third of the world's soils are
degraded meaning its ability to support
plants and animals is diminished it's
vanishing too each year the un estimates
around 75 billion tons are eroded from
croplands just washed or blown away
but it could be one of our most
effective tools in the fight against
climate change if we treat our soils
right they could suck up four to five
billion tons more carbon each year
that's 10 of humanity's greenhouse gas
emissions and that could happen quickly
soil may not look much but it is amazing
it teams with unseen creatures
is at the root of nearly all our food
and even has the uncanny ability to
bring death
back to life so how come in recent years
we've treated it like dirt
farming practices across much of the
world damaged soil by slicing it up with
plows threatening its biology with
chemicals and now we know the climate is
paying a price too carbon dioxide
escapes from the earth and warms the
atmosphere
[Music]
but here on a research farm in devon the
scientists are fighting back
here at northwick they monitor pretty
much everything not only what goes onto
the field but also what comes off it in
terms of the gases and also things held
in the water they reckon this is the
most instrumented farm in the world
andy why are we all talking about
soylent and frankly rather worried about
it
well soil shouldn't be a natural
reservoir for organic carbon
theoretically it should be holding more
carbon in soil than than we see in the
atmosphere in the above ground biomass
but the way we're growing our food is
really having quite a detrimental effect
on the amount of organic matter that we
have in our soils so tell me about the
two clumps you've got in your hand so
well let's start with the good one the
the the soil here is from a permanent
pasture that we have here on site you'll
notice that it's it's very lots of
fibrous roots in there it breaks apart
it
it has a lovely structure it falls apart
quite nicely it's almost kind of hairy
looking it is very heavy up by its own
hair yeah there's a lot of root mass in
there uh now if we compare that to soil
that we take out of this this barley
field this has only been
used for growing cereals for three years
but you can already see that the quality
of the soil structure
is is completely different this is
more like a brick whereas this is more
like a sponge
but andy along with many climate
scientists believes soil can be turned
into an ally in the fight against
climate change our mistreatment of soil
over the last century or so does mean
that we have an opportunity here to
correct that and get some of that carbon
dioxide back out of the atmosphere but
there's a problem our chemical
fertilizers and industrial farming have
given us bumper harvests and with the
war in ukraine threatening food supply
feeding the world has to be a priority
can we bring carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere into the soil while still
maintaining levels of food production
our experiments suggest that you can get
close using purely organic matter so
composted farmyard manure for instance
but our highest yielding plots are the
ones that combine farmyard manure with a
little bit of bag nitrogen so a
combination of organic and inorganic
probably gets us the highest
yields but also benefits the soil
40 miles to the south the new manager of
this farm has gone cold turkey on
chemicals and intensive farming choosing
to build soil health instead the
opportunity is to turn this around and
to yeah to demonstrate that farming can
actually be a hero of the climate crisis
tim williams took over here just 18
months ago this was a
conventional arable farm the soil and
itself the structure's quite damaged
and so trying to
return the health back to the soil and
so to do that one of the first things
that i do is put livestock back into the
system
and he's growing different crops and
grasses ending fertilizer use and
stopping plowing a core farming practice
basically by plowing you're completely
inverting the soil so you're you're
destroying the homes of all the worms
and the fungi and the bacteria you
imagine the soil as london you've got
skyscrapers you've got little houses
you've got
rivers you've got tubes you've you know
the underground and and basically by
plowing you're destroying those homes
and
yeah complete destruction essentially
farming like this isn't just a way to
fight climate change as fertilizer
prices spike it could also wean us off
our addiction to increasingly expensive
chemicals
[Music]
maybe now it's soils time to shine
this rediscovered respect for soil isn't
just for farmers i've become a bit
obsessed about it in my own little plot
every scrap of food and nearly all the
clippings from the garden are earthbound
as you can see here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and after sitting here for a year all
this stuff gets spread
on the allotment here under this plastic
and it sits there for about another 12
months hopefully making very happy soil
it's nice to think our gardens could be
storing carbon alongside yielding a few
spuds beans and greens and healthier
soils hold more water too something of
growing importance as our summers get
drier
and to find out how gardeners may need
to adapt i've been to the royal botanic
gardens in queue to talk to their
curator of living collections great
title simon toomer
it's been extremely dry we haven't had
any real rain for probably over well
over a month now really we've had a few
sprinklings but they don't really make a
lot of difference so now it's pretty
parched
what's suffering as a result
yeah particularly some of the summer
flowering plants some of the things like
roses don't enjoy this kind of weather
daily is gladiola you know those summer
flowering bulbs and particularly some of
the young trees
most plants go through quite a
vulnerable period when they've just been
planted and if that coincides with this
kind of weather you know we
they they don't like it at all actually
so we are having to water some of the
young trees now question about grass i
mean it is clearly brown around us here
whether or not you mind the look of it
is brown grass dead grass
uh no i mean grass is really well
adapted actually to these kind of
conditions although it looks dreadful
you know it is able to survive
and always comes back i mean i've seen
this kind of conditions a few times and
uh
remarkably it will it will come back
yeah if we are moving into a
an era of possibly hotter drier summers
what plants or trees do you think we're
going to see more of well we're sitting
here at queue in in part of the garden
we call the mediterranean garden and
actually you know the cues the the the
clues in the name to some extent you
know if we look south you know we see
the kind of plants that are
are growing in the climate that we're
almost certainly going to have in the
future so we're looking at things some
of them are quite
familiar garden plants actually rosemary
bay um sisters you know the rock roses
all those kinds of plants um we can even
see olives and
cork oak in this part of the garden but
there
there's also a lot a lot of the other
plants aren't going to disappear you
know even we may have to adapt our
choice of roses for example and they
will survive you know we will still see
those in our garden but we are
undoubtedly going to see a different
kind of a palette or a different palette
of plants in the future what about
what's around us here these things we
might see more of yeah the
the pines are stone pine mediterranean
pine species and they they're they
they're the tree that give us the the
little pine nuts that we're using pesto
and we've also got a rosemary there um
and the little dwarf palm anyone who
spends
time in the mediterranean place like
majorca will be familiar with that plant
so you think there's beauty to be found
in a dryer garden isn't it there is and
you know the the examples you've given
they're not particularly colorful i mean
i think they're very attractive in their
own way and they complement other things
but there's no reason to think we can't
still have a really nice floriferous
beautiful colorful gardens just that
it's going to be different we're going
to have to manage them in a different
way
some great tips from simon there and we
seem to have gone for a bit of a
clothing echo
coming up after the break a glimpse of a
positive breakthrough in washington as a
u.s democratic senator has announced his
surprise support to pass the largest
climate investment in the country's
history
welcome back to the show in a week that
might go down as one of the most
significant in american efforts to fight
climate change
a surprise breakthrough in normally
deadlocked washington politics enables
the largest ever federal investment in
clean energy and a total climate change
spending package of 370 billion dollars
now that is a big chunk of change by any
measure and to give you a comparison
it's nearly twice as much as we spend on
the nhs each year
so might the shift in political mood be
down to continuing extreme weather
convincing more voters that climate
change is a real and present danger
just this week several people were
killed in extraordinary flash floods in
kentucky while saint louis missouri also
saw unprecedented rainfall and flooding
much of the pacific northwest region has
roasted temperatures hit nearly 39
degrees in the city of portland with the
state's mayor declaring a state of
emergency
between two and three thousand cattle
were reported killed by the excessive
heat in kansas one of the big beef
producing states meanwhile intense
wildfires have hit alaska unlike
anything seen before in a place more
associated with snow more than 500 fires
have burnt across the state this year
and fire season took off dramatically in
california when a blaze ripped through
land near yosemite national park
joe pike reports
while washington witnessed a
breakthrough california burned
the largest fastest growing fire this
season
battling it three thousand firefighters
including jeremy snyder and his
battalion they work 24-hour shifts it's
mentally and physically challenging
and after 25 years in the job he has
noticed a change we're seeing that
growth in that fire activity earlier and
earlier every year and do you think that
climate change has played a role in all
of this yeah there's definitely um you
know something that's happened over the
last couple years you know 10 years
we've definitely seen a lot more fire
growth you know rapid fire growth
um intense fires that are burning
through communities like we haven't seen
really in the past
they are fighting to save the homes of
people like jacqueline and peter
native americans and climate campaigners
who believe global warming is a big
factor in the crisis they're now facing
they say you know if he doesn't affect
me it doesn't matter
you know yeah but it's affecting both of
you but it's affecting but it's
affecting everybody affecting everybody
and for people who are watching this who
don't believe in climate change
what would you say to them i'd say pay
attention you know
really pay attention to what's going on
with the earth and why it's different
because it is let you know
let's we need to stop being so selfish
the drive into the evacuated area is
eerie
just a few days ago this was green
woodland
but the change now is dramatic at first
for a split second it almost feels like
a winter scene
because there are no leaves on the trees
and they have this
slightly white gray color but of course
that's not snow
it's ash and this isn't winter
it's the height of summer
cars have been left as metal skeletons
homes
utterly destroyed
wildfires are nothing new in california
and there are a range of reasons for
them the intense drought parched
vegetation low humidity
high heat but climate change has
contributed to all of that if you live
here it is unavoidable and yet in this
country it remains a divisive issue
constitution of the united states
elected on a promise of climate action
congratulations mr president joe biden
has struggled to turn his hopes into
reality partly due to one of his own
democratic senators
in west virginia we
understand that climate change is real
joe manchin represents coal country and
in a finely balanced congress had been
blocking progress
until now this bill
would be the most significant
legislation in history to tackle the
climate crisis and improve our energy
security right away
the multi-billion dollar legislation
could be approved within days but
california's wildfire season will
continue for months joe pike sky news
and as ever you can find more details on
that story and all our other climate
content by scanning this qr code or on
skynews.com
forward slash climate
so big developments in the actual and
political weather in the u.s this week
what about here in the uk
drought has been the big story and i've
been talking to skies katharina vitozi
who's in the isle of man where they
declared the year's first hosepipe ban
hi katarina the first thing i could see
a lot of grey clouds behind your head
any hint of rain well the forecast says
it was going to be dry and actually when
i was speaking to some people here who
had
been doing beautiful walks around this
reservoir the forecast is for it to be
continually dry over the next couple of
days but it looks like there is there is
some strong sunshine behind those clouds
so unfortunately that that much needed
rain i don't think it's it's going to
come any time soon
so hosepipe band there and now we've
heard elsewhere as well yes so i'm on
the isle of man it's where as you say
the first hose pipe ban uh has come into
force
it is quite in an interesting situation
here and these talking to the utility
companies that have introduced this
temporary usage ban which we all know as
hose pipe bands
they say it's very much a precautionary
measure
and here on the isle of man they've got
reservoir supply only it's not like in
other parts of the country where they
you know draw on rivers and there might
be aquifers here it's very much
reservoir first and they really need to
guard that supply because it's finite
and it's very much dependent on what
falls out of the sky and it does tell us
something that this this water stress
isn't just limited to the southeast it
goes quite a way across the country i
know the
the northern ireland and the far west of
scotland have had it pretty wet but most
the rest of the country seems pretty
parched
yeah the isle of man in the northwest
not typically an area you would think
struggles for much in the way of rain
but they say it's been it's been dry
here and like many parts of the country
when we saw those higher temperatures
last week and the warm weather around
that they saw a peak in demand by about
20 percent and as i said the supply they
have here is finite um i i don't think
it was very surprising to see the news
from southern water that it was also
going to be introducing a hosepipe ban
when we were having
discussions about what were the driest
parts of the uk the messages we were
getting from the environment agency was
very much southern england eastern
england and also yorkshire as well but
clearly as you say it's not just those
areas that have been affected but i
understand a very different nature of
water supply in that southern water
region so
mainly coming from groundwater so why
have they decided to bring in the
hosepipe down there so they say there is
no risk at the moment to customer water
supply so drinking water effectively but
they say what is at risk at the minute
is the habitats that surround two major
rivers at the river itching and the
river test
and
southern water we understand at the
moment is the only water company that
applied for what's known as a drought
permit so that if we do get into the
stage of an official drought they would
be able to use extra amounts of water
from those rivers to to enhance supply
but sort of by going in preemptively
with this hose pipe band that they hope
that by to managing
demand they can avoid having to over
extract from these rivers because there
are precious habitats and organisms that
rely on these river iron environments
fish in some parts of the country the
couples of england and shropshire
they've also got crayfish that have been
massively affected so there are precious
river environments that we know as water
level water levels drop are already
seeing an impact we don't have to wait
or they don't have to wait for there to
be an official drought to feel the
impact of these dropping river levels
caterina thanks very much
the connectivity of nature and our place
within it witnessed in the current
drought would have been well understood
by a pioneer of environmental thinking
who died this week james lovelock
created the gaia theory named the greek
goddess of earth which sees the world as
a living organism somewhat threatened by
human behavior he was 103. well joining
me to discuss his work and his legacy is
tim lenton professor of climate change
and earth system science at the
university of exeter uh tim thanks very
much for joining us just before we get
to his if you like professional
contribution you knew him as a friend
yeah he was a wonderful man jim very
humble
wicked sense of humor
enormous fun to be around really
and someone i owe a huge debt of
gratitude to because uh he set me on my
own personal scientific path
right from when i was an 18 year old kid
and i wrote to him saying i'm so
inspired by your books i really want to
study this and he he had the humility to
write back and invite me to meet him and
it all started from there wow amazing
now this idea of a sort of connected
earth is kind of familiar to us now but
when did he come up with the guy theory
and i guess it was it pretty
revolutionary then
it certainly was because it was
1965 when he started thinking this way
and he came to this idea not by thinking
about the earth but because he was
employed by nasa
in the design of what became the viking
missions to land on mars and look to see
if there was life on mars
and lovelock's key insight was hold on
if there's life on any planet it's going
to show up in the composition of the
atmosphere
and maybe we don't actually need to go
to mars
to work out if there's life there and
then he looked back at the earth and saw
oh yeah the earth has this extraordinary
atmosphere dominated by 20 oxygen made
by living things
complete chemical cocktail of stuff that
reacts together all the time and yet
it's stable over
huge periods of time so
then he intuited wow life could be both
creating and regulating the composition
of the atmosphere and with that the
climate yeah and in the mid to late 60s
wow that's so far ahead of its time well
indeed and you were talking about long
periods of time and he was born in 1919
i mean the amount of environmental
change you'd have witnessed in that more
than a century it's kind of staggering
isn't it
and i think that really shaped his his
sensitivity for the earth and for gaia
because he'd grown up um with his father
a naturalist who taught him the birds by
their song the different flowers and the
hedgerows and then he saw you know
industrial agriculture
um kill off those birds and the
butterflies and everything else and he
saw the world the world he knew near him
changing he'd grown up in brixton in
london
um
and i think that must have informed his
sensitivity he had for blimey we are
profoundly
disrupting our life support system and
then he gave us this amazing insight
into that life support system on a
planetary scale
well tim you must be really missing such
a a powerful thinker an influential man
thank you very much indeed for your time
thank you tom
now we've not had much time for many of
your questions this week but here is one
wayne asks in the light of water
shortages and the fires we saw here in
the uk last week whether we could use
seawater to both put out wildfires and
prevent them by soaking the land and the
answer to that is in short yes and no
in an emergency water is scooped up from
the sea by firefighting aircraft like
this one off a beach in spain and dumped
on or near a blaze to hold it back
but dr joel hershey from the national
oceanography center told us that in the
long term seawater can be very damaging
only a few terrestrial plants such as
mangroves like these ones in senegal can
live on sea water the salt content
otherwise actually dehydrates most
plants and causes them to die
and of course we'd like more questions
from you so go to sky news dot com
forward slash climate or any of our
social media accounts and put in your
questions and comments
well that's all we've got time for this
week but if you have any spare moments
whether it's on your garden or just in
your window box don't forget to show a
little love for your soil bye
[Music]
you